this video is brought to you by keeps
keeps treatments up to 90 percent
effective at reducing further hair loss
head to keeps calm /bi graphics to learn
more and get 50% off your first order it
was one of the greatest states in
history in the early 20th century the
austro-hungarian Empire dominated
Central Europe at its height it
stretched all the way from modern-day
Montenegro right up to the Czech German
border ruled for centuries by a
succession of Habsburg Emperor's it
seemed as permanent as the United States
does today yet in late 1918 in the blink
of an eye this great Empire collapsed
man who kicked its foundations out well
that would be an inexperienced 31 year
old Dylan songs known to history as call
the first The Last Emperor of Austria
before E dynamite at his own Empire Karl
had been an obscure royal from a side
branch of the Habsburg dynasty but a
combination of freak tragedies had seen
him propelled to the height of power
made Emperor before he was even 30 Karl
inherited an empire on the losing side
of one of the greatest wars in history
in his short reign he first tried to
hold his disintegrating world together
before finally surrendering to its
destruction an emperor who killed his
empire a soldier who may become a saint
this is the fascinating story of
Austria's last emperor
[Music]
fitting for a man whose reign revolved
around war Karl's story started with a
bullet well specifically it started with
two bullets two shots fired in a
palatial hunting lodge outside Vienna
one cold miserable night in January 1889
earlier that day the disturbed young
heir to the Austrian throne Crown Prince
Rudolf had requested his 17-year old
lover join him at the lodge there the
two made a suicide pact before Rudolf
shot her and then turned the gun on
himself
her death of the heir shook the Empire
it created a scandal that engulfed
Vienna and emotionally broke the Emperor
Franz Josef but it did something else to
it said call on a collision course with
destiny born a year and a half earlier
in August the 17th 1887 karl was a young
boy from a side branch of the Habsburg
royal family his father
Archduke Otto was the nephew of Emperor
Franz Josef and younger brother of
Archduke Franz Ferdinand but while both
the Franz's were famous for their pious
Catholic lifestyles Karl's father was
infamous for treating life like one
giant frat party he drank he caroused he
had affairs that scandalized Austria
naturally this didn't sit well with his
wife princess Maria Josepha was a strict
Catholic who couldn't believe her
real-life Disney Prince it turned out to
be Gaston - the muscles from moments
Carl was born she avoided a husband in
favor of her son taking him to mass
almost every day it was a habit that
would instill in the young boy a deep
affinity for Catholicism as that was the
family set up but not so abnormal tale
of parental division that could have
gone unchanged for decades had Rudolf
not fard those fatal shots since
Ferdinand was childless that meant Carl
was now third in line to the throne
well technically Franz Ferdinand was
only childless because he was still a
young it was fully expected that he
would marry and start creating many
Hapsburgs that would knock call-back out
of the running to be Emperor so no one
made any special effort to start
preparing call for life at the tot he
was allowed to skip the standard
Habsburg military upbringing and instead
attended a regular school but events
would soon conspired to keep calls place
in the succession in 1900 Franz
and married Sofia char tack now sophie
was a Czech countess but for a family is
absurdly royal and as absurdly Austrian
as the Hapsburgs Czech countess was
practically synonymous with
trailer-trash enraged by to match
Franz Josef excluded Franz Ferdinand's
future children from the line of
succession and just like that it dawns
on everyone that Carl one day really
would be Emperor it was too late to
stick call on the military track so his
parents allowed him to go to university
in Prague and get a regular education in
the grand Czech city kaul absorbed ideas
and attitudes alien to his family
becoming a cosmopolitan reformist even
as he held on to his strong Catholicism
at first the Emperor must have consoled
himself that the throne was still a long
way from the boys grasp but well soon
got closer on November the 1st 1906
Carl's father also passed away from
syphilis making Carl second in line
behind only Franz Ferdinand's now all it
would take would be a single accidents
or say a single assassin's bullet and
19-year old Carl would be the heir
presumptive no one knew it's in 1906 but
an assassin's bullet was already in
Franz Ferdinand's future and when it was
finally fired it was going to change the
entire world
[Music]
for the next eight years Cal suffered a
crash course in the kind of lives
Habsburg heirs were expected to live
with the young students now getting
worryingly close to power franz joseph
abandoned his previous detachments and
worked flat-out to with the coal into
shape
the boy was removed from university
refused the chance to finish his degree
and dumped onto an emergency military
track that swim whisked away to
Garrison's all over the Empire he was
also bumped into an arranged marriage
with a bride the Emperor thought was
worthy the suitably wealthy suitably
royal zita of bourbon-parma there's
actually footage of the elderly Franz
Josef at the couple's wedding watching
them closely like a hawk suspicious its
prey might run off at any moment he
needn't worried
despite their arranged marriage Carl and
Zita got along fine bonding over their
shared Catholic faith and interest in
new ideas but while Franz Josef may have
breathed a sigh of relief over the
wedding there were already signs of
trouble although call was now having a
normal half smug upbringing no one was
actually showing him how to run an
empire Franz Josef kept him at arm's
length from court possibly on the
assumption that Carl could learn later
when Franz Ferdinand was Emperor it was
a risky decision by the time of cols
wedding Franz Josef was already in his
80s his relationship with his heir Franz
Ferdinand was still in the sewer from
the whole Sophie chotek thing if Franz
Joseph wanted to pass any wisdom on well
now is the time to do it but maybe the
Emperor was simply too busy come 1911
after all his empire was creaking at the
scenes although it was known as
austria-hungary the Empire Carl would
soon inherit was far bigger than just
those two countries alongside Austria
and Hungary it also comprised modern-day
Czech Republic Slovakia Slovenia Croatia
and Bosnia alongside parts of modern-day
Montenegro Italy Poland Serbia Ukraine
and Romania that means in multicultural
empire filled with different ethnicities
religions and languages it was this
multiculturalism that had allowed Vienna
to thrive in the 19th century it was
also what was now threatening to pull it
all apart nationalism was on the rise
across Europe within the Empire the
biggest flash points were the succession
minded Czech lands and
the newly acquired territory of Bosnia
the latter was especially volatile only
annexed by the Empire in 1908 its status
as part of austria-hungary it was bit of
a sore spot for many Bosnian Serbs who
dreamed of joining Bosnia and Serbia
into a single nation but although Franz
Joseph was aware of the problems in
Bosnia he seemingly didn't realize just
how acute they had become until it was
too late on July the 28th 1914 Karl's
uncle Franz Ferdinand's visited Sarajevo
as part of his tour of Bosnia while he
was being driven through the city in an
open-topped car a young Bosnian Serb
named Gavrilo Princip stepped out of the
crowd and fired two shots just as
Rudolph's two fatal shots had many
decades before these two shots fired and
Sarajevo would change history the
assassination of Franz Ferdinand's meant
Karl became heir presumptive suddenly
from a minor royal this boy of not yet
twenty-five had been propelled to the
very cusp of power but no one apart from
Karl was thinking about this in mid 1914
the assassination of Franz Ferdinand had
already created much bigger problems
convinced the Serbian government had
been behind the murder Franz Joseph
declared war this led to Russia coming
to Serbia aid which led to Germany
coming to austria-hungary Zaid which led
to France coming to Russia's aid and so
on and so on until the entire continent
was marching to you a military drumbeat
World War one had just begun the
deadliest conflict the human race had
seen so far and it would spends the next
four years ravaging Europe by the time
it ended in November 1918 Karl would be
emperor of an empire that no longer
existed
you
despite now being heir to the throne
coal was still technically a soldier so
when the largest war ever seen broke out
he did what soldiers do he went off to
fight
although the Western Front gets all the
english-language press the Eastern Front
was no picnic by the time Carl reached
kaliesha the little slice of Ukraine the
Empire owned the bloodshed had already
reached staggering heights along the
fronts the Russian Empire was making
mincemeat of the austro-hungarians in
the first two months of fighting alone
the Russians managed to push 300
kilometers into Austrian territory
capturing Lemberg now known as the vivre
and killing over a hundred thousand
Austrian soldiers but while the Romanov
family was sitting pretty in some
Petersburg Paul witnessed the slaughter
firsthand to say it had an effect on the
young man would be an understatement
we've read sources that say he tried
praying on the battlefield just to make
the bloodshed stop but if God was up
there
he wasn't in the mood for listening from
September to May the Russians battered
the austro-hungarian army as they did so
a few things became painfully clear to
Karl the first was that the army was
weak not just because it was in urgent
need of modernization but because there
was something rotten in austria-hungary
itself the siren song of nationalism was
fraying the Empire's bonds making its
different ethnicities mistrustful
unwilling to fight as a team the second
was that the main threat to the army
might not be the marauding Russians but
rather getting swallowed by the German
war machine during the goal it said
tarnów offensive in mid 1915 Karl saw
firsthand how it was only with German
firepower that the Empire was capable of
fighting on over the next 18 months
called toward the various fronts of
World War one noting with increasing
alarm the Empire's growing problems in
northern Italy he saw about ready to
throw off the Habsburg yokas subjects
were on the Eastern Front he watched as
Russian manpower smashed the
austro-hungarian armies until the morale
was just non-existent by late 1916 it
was badly clear that even if the Central
Powers won the stress of fighting might
kill the Empire stone-dead what was
desperately needed was someone new in
charge someone with a vision for how to
stop the slaughter and pacify the
empires and
any ethnic groups naturally Karl assumes
that he should be that someone and he
was about to get that chance in the
early hours of November the 21st 1916
Emperor Franz Josef passed away in his
bedchamber in Vienna after ruling the
Ambar for nearly sixty eight years
immediately karl was recalled from the
front arriving in vienna shortly after
there amid the cold grandeur of the
imperial city he was proclaimed call the
first emperor of austria at the moment
he took the title he was only 29 years
old from the NGO karl was determined to
act on the lessons it learned on the
front that meant ending the war and
ending it soon he even insisted on
having the following phrase inserted
into his coronation Proclamation I will
do everything to banish in the shortest
possible time the horrors and sacrifices
of war to win back for my peoples these
sorely missed blessings of peace but
despite the new Emperor's grand dreams
the reality was that peace just wasn't
his to give by wins in 1916
austria-hungary was completely reliant
on Germany and the chances of the Kaiser
agreeing to peace but somewhere around
the chances of the Kaiser agreeing to
put on heels and do a little dance for
Karl in a Berlin nightclub the call was
not to be deterred even as he was
hastily arranging his separate
coronation in the Hungarian half of the
empire the young emperor was coming up
with a dangerous plan the Kaiser would
like Karl pursue peace then karl was
just going to have to go over the old
man's head to get it and speaking of
heads did you know that two out of every
three guys will experience some form of
male pattern baldness by the time
they're 35 well I know for sure for me
it was more like 25 but thanks
statistics I wish today sponsor keeps
had been around when I was younger
because advancements in science have
meant that there are now treatments that
can combat the symptoms of hair loss and
help you keep the hair
that you might have look it's too late
for me my hair is not coming back but
you don't have to leave it too late
better yet you don't have to go broke
doing it and let you hear about
medicines you kind of just assumed
they're really expensive that's not the
case with keeps it started just $10 a
month you can also get prescription
shampoo which will help keep your scalp
healthy so how does it work well there's
no need to visit a doctor's office you
just have an online consultation and
then a discrete package arrives at your
door and you can take it into the
privacy of your own home and use it in
privacy and look prevention is key here
guys
otherwise this will be a really weird ad
so if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss Kurt keeps calm or
would slash by graphics and you'll get
50% off your first order again keeps
calm /by graphics and let's get back to
the video if Carl wanted his empire to
make peace with the Allies the first
thing he had to do was make sure it's
survived long enough the disease of
nationalism had by now spread to Vienna
itself fearing the divisions if
ultra-right Austrians were given too
much control Carl made one of his first
acts hiring prominent checks into his
cabinet it was a move meant to
neutralize the threat of czech secession
instead just meant carl became as
unpopular with the Austrians as he was
with everybody else and unpopular was
exactly the last thing that Karl wanted
to be right now that March 1917 the
February revolution shook Russia
toppling the Tsar and yes we agree it's
confusing that a revolution named after
the month of February took place in
March you can blame Imperial Russia's
weird love affair with the Julian
calendar for that one anyway the wrong
month revolution but the fear of God in
Tikal who started to worry that he might
be next if he didn't get that whole
peace thing sorted out he got his wife
Zita to contact her brothers Sixtus and
Xavier who were already fighting on the
Allied side he then gave them a secret
note to hand to the French telling them
austria-hungary wanted to make peace
today these Sixtus affair is infamous
for making car look like a bit of a
jackass butts back in March and April of
1917 it briefly looks like the key to
ending the war when the French received
calls over tears they laid out a list of
cautious demands as a precondition for
talks when Karl immediately agreed to
most of them the French contacted London
being all like whoa this guy is actually
serious everyone was so excited by the
messages the British Prime Minister
Lloyd George remarked that means peace
but of course Lloyd George was wrong
while Carr was happy to leave Germany
hanging willing to return land to Serbia
and willing to recognize French claims
to new territory he just couldn't bring
himself to give up the hapsburgs last
remaining chunks of Italy since Italy
was demanding he do just that in return
for peace the secret negotiations
eventually fizzled with hindsight Carr's
actions were pretty super dumb
austria-hungary's holdings in Italy were
already small while abandoning them
would have been a bitter pill to swallow
it could have allowed the Empire to
survive but that was just one of
contradictions he was a wannabe
peacemaker but he was also the guy who
literally thought the Catholic God
appointed him to rule an indivisible
Empire with that mindset surrendering
territory was always gonna be a bit of a
non-starter but even though Carl's
negotiations fell through it wasn't the
end of the Sixtus affair on January the
8th 1918 Woodrow Wilson sent out his 14
points for peace in Europe including
self-determination for all peoples of
Karl's Empire a move that almost
guaranteed its dissolution when Karl
subsequently tried to make more strident
tone against the Allies the French
published his secret letters this is the
bit of the Sixtus affair that everyone
remembers and it was as embarrassing as
it sounds for the Allies this was final
proof that austria-hungary was close to
collapse for Germany it was nothing
short of betrayal that May the Kaiser
angrily summoned Karl in a special
meeting he forced the young Emperor to
put the austro-hungarian military
totally under Berlin's control with the
empire now little more than a German
vassal state writing was on the wall
there was no way Karl was escaping this
quagmire without some serious
consequences but not even the failed
Emperor could have foreseen just how
serious those consequences would be
[Music]
across 1918 Carl tried his best to shore
up support inside his ailing empire he
introduced military reforms banned
flogging tried to halt the use of poison
gas on the domestic front set up a
welfare system for returning soldiers
and tried to demilitarize his society
but it was too little too late
when austria-hungary entered the war it
was not a given that it would collapse
had caused peace efforts succeeded in
1917 it seems likely some form of the
Empire would have survived - its Italian
Serbian and probably polish and Czech
parts but it would have still been an
empire by fall 1918 though ship had long
since sales on October the 16th called
published a manifesto broadly accepting
Wilson's fourteen points declaring the
creation of a federal Empire and
granting every nationality autonomy but
it was all just theater by now it was
clear that World War one was in his
endgame and it was clear who was on the
losing side just 12 days after Karl
published his manifesto on October the
28th the Czechs took control of Prague
and declared their independence the very
next day Croatia and Slovenia
unilaterally seceded the day after
savatya JumpShip that same day Austria's
politicians declared the creation of a
new national parliament effectively
taking Austria out of its own Empire
within 24 hours
Hungary's new leaders dissolved the
treaty joining their country with
Austria on November the 11th with only a
handful of fragments of his empire left
Carl gave up on trying to hold on he
renounced his right to rule Austria
released her subjects from their oath of
loyalty and announced that he would
retreat from politics it wasn't quite an
abdication but it was very very close as
the guns fell silent along the fronts at
11:00 a.m. that same day austria-hungary
officially ceased to exist
it seems Carl still had hope at this
point hope his grateful subjects would
recall him for his peace efforts and
asked him to lead them once again it was
a nice fantasy but well fantasy was all
it was
while some corps called the peace
emperor today the fact is that he
totally failed in his goal of making
peace World War one had just shattered
Europe it had claimed over 20 million
lives no one but no one wanted to be led
by one of the guys who was on
losing's I'd come March 1919 even Carl
seemed to recognize this at the ends of
that month he and Zita boarded a train
bound for Switzerland's and set off for
a lonely life as exile in the wake of
their departure the Austrian national
parliament passed a law banning all
Hapsburgs from the country and stripping
them of their right to the throne any
sensible person would see this was the
ends that this video was coming to its
close that the credits are about to roll
on Carl's life but Carl wasn't sensible
he was an idealist and a man who thought
God had hand-picked him for greatness as
he crossed the Swiss border the deposed
Emperor issued his felt car manifesto
revolving around his own decision to
step down and announcing that he would
return to lead austria-hungary again it
was a moment as brazen as it was foolish
it was also a moment that would soon
plunge the shattered Empire right back
into chaos
although with hindsight we can see that
carl's reign was over things weren't so
certain in 1919 France actually toyed
with restoring him and rebuilding his
empire as a counterweight to Germany it
was just spitballing but words somehow
got back to call whose takeaway was that
Paris would support him retaking the
throne by force
the only problem was there wasn't a
throne for him to go back to or was
there in world's war ones aftermath
Hungary very quickly went through a
phase of communist rule which ended with
everyone really super keen to sort of do
the exact opposite of communism in
February 1920 McCloskey came to power
restored the monarchy and named himself
Regent in Carl's name for call this was
a clear signal that the Hungarians at
least wanted him back and he wasn't
totally mistaken but there was one
Hungarian determined to make sure that
Carl never retook his throne horthy may
have restored the monarchy but only as a
means to power after all what sir
regents when his king is capable of
ruling lassen nobody so when karl
knocked back into hungary in disguise on
March the 26th 1921 Hoth he did
everything in his power to keep the
young man from unseating him when they
met he told Karl that of course he
supported him that of course it helped
in march on budapest then when the
emperor was good and mollified horthy
snuck off and asked the french if they
were actually serious about supporting
karl
so all these delights the French were
not serious about it at all
Paris announced that had no part of this
and Carl was both an idiot and on his
own this delighted Prague and the
czechoslovaks immediately threatened to
declare war on hungry if it restored the
Emperor and that is how call wound up
fleeing into exile in Switzerland for
the second time but the last Emperor he
wasn't done trying just yet
that fall call contacted Hungary's
elites making sure to exclude horthy he
managed to drum up an army of 5000
loyalists on October the 20th the
Emperor flew our planes at the border
town of Sauron where his army was
waiting for him initially the venture
had all the hallmarks of a glorious
homecoming the people of sovereigns
celebrated calls returned as his army
began the long march to Budapest more
and more joined their ranks for one
shining moments it really looks like
calm was going to get his empire back
and then the army reached Budapest
and everything fell apart no one quite
seems sure what happened that strange
day we've seen sources claimed horthy
trick to the citizens into taking up
arms against Carl believing he was at
the hairdo they check a Slovak invasion
force we've seen others say that Carl
was betrayed by one of his generals the
only thing certain is the call entered
Budapest on October the 23rd by October
the 24th had been captured and his last
chance restoration was over this time it
wouldn't end with comfy exile in
Switzerland on November the 1st the
irate British sailed a warship up the
Danube and demanded Carl be handed over
they then took him away away from
Hungary away from mainland Europe away
to the Portuguese islands of Madeira
some 900 kilometers from the mainland
and they left him there on April the 1st
1922 Carl succumbed to pneumonia some
sources say Spanish flu and passed away
aged just 34 at the time he died his
name was mud across Europe his former
Nations had all passed laws banning him
from their territory it was seen as a
weakling best and a laughingstock at
worst
but things soon started to change in the
aftermath of world war ii with its
overly evil trio of hitler mussolini and
stalin a bumbling Habsburg who sincerely
tried to make peace suddenly didn't look
so bad as World War 1 began to be viewed
as a gigantic needless morally gray
screw up calls determination to end the
war eventually began to appear decent
even noble in 2004 over 80 years after
Austria's last Emperor died in misery
pope john paul ii beautified him for his
peacemaking efforts as of the time of
writing this episode karl is on the path
to sainthood is it the fate he deserves
who can say while coal really did try to
make peace II was also really a bit of
an ineffectual bundler and he failed in
the war that his empire was a part of
they say that all it takes for evil to
triumph is for good men to do nothing
what they neglect to mention is that
sometimes good men can really try to do
something and still fail to stop the
slaughter karl may have been a decent
man deep down but if his story shows us
any
think it's that decency isn't always
enough sometimes you can do everything
in your power to hold your country
together and you can still wind up being
known to history as the last emperor so
I hope you found that video interesting
if you did please like this video
subscribe hit that notification bell if
you feel like it also support this
channel by supporting our fantastic
sponsor keeps you'll find a link to them
below and thank you for watching
[Music]